ich glaube dass die hohen
gasenstrompreise die wir erleben auf
Dauer nicht durchhaltbar sind für unser
Land und neben den Hilfsmaßnahmen die
wir jetzt einleiten müssen wir auf dem
Markt einfach mehr Energie anbieten das
heißt für mich dass wir nicht nur jetzt
die beiden Atomkraftwerke bis zum früher
weiterlaufen lassen weil das Problem
nach diesem Winter nicht vorbei sein
wird wir brauchen länger Kernkraft ich
glaube wir sollten auch über die
Reaktivierung der stillgelegen
Kernkraftwerke nachdenken und aus meiner
Sicht auch immer mehr Einheimische
Erdgasförderung denn es ist absurd dass
wir aus den USA frechen Gas importieren
wollen aber selbst nicht bereit sind Gas
in Deutschland zu fördern
Herr Herbst hier habe ich die Frage die
ostsee-pipelines die Beschäftigen ein
Jahr sehr stark und wir wollen hier
definitiv nicht mutmaßen aber weiß man
schon mehr im Bundestag nein wir tappen
genauso im Dunkeln wieder allgemeine
Öffentlichkeit also wer die sabotiert
hat wissen wir nicht dass es keine
natürliche Ursache war ist Glas
warenexplosion die extern ausgeführt
worden aber an drei Stellen war wenn ich
wieder gebe und man darf ja nicht
vergessen die die Nord Stream 2 ist ja
völlig neu die Pipeline also die war ja
nicht mal Betrieb das heißt vom Material
kann es keine Materialermüdung sein aber
glauben Sie oder denken Sie dass es
einen Weg zurück gibt zu den
Handelsbeziehungen mit Russland also ich
glaube unter Putty nicht ehrlich gesagt
und ich glaube die zweite Lehre ist wir
sollen uns nie wieder so abhängig von
einem Lieferanten machen wir waren bei
55% erdgasimporten von Russland abhängig
das würde ich auch mit keinem anderen
Land mehr machen egal welches Land auf
der Welt man sollte immer
diversifizieren auch kein Unternehmen
würde 70 Prozent des Umsatz mit einem
einzigen Kunden machen weil wenn der
wegbricht bist du auch neben dem Platz
war ein anderes Land vergleichbar
abhängig was Ihnen einfällt naja die
Italiener sind abhängig auch von von
Gaslieferungen gewesen und ich sag mal
wir müssen diversifizieren und ich
glaube der Fehler war dass wir so eine
Energiewende gemacht haben die hieß wir
bauen ein paar Windräder an Land auf und
die gesamte Reserve bei Windstille das
machen wir alles mit russischem Gas und
damit ist die Energiewende krachen
gescheitert wir müssen auf mehrere
Standbeine setzen dazu gehört dass man
sich Kernkraft offshore Windkraft weil
die einfach zuverlässiger ist auch Solar
aber eben auch einheimischer
in Deutschland fracken wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe dass wir die
Reserven nutzen sollten das kann sicher
gemacht werden das zeigen ja auch die
seriösen Studien die es heute gibt dass
wenn man das sauber ausführt dass man
das ordentlich machen kann und wir haben
ungefähr ein Reserven das 30-fache des
deutschen Jahres Gas Verbrauchs was bei
uns im Boden liegt und es hat auch eine
wirtschaftliche Komponente warum sind
wir nur anderen Ländern für Gas Geld
zahlen warum nutzen wir nicht selbst die
wirtschaftlichen Potenziale wird das
aktuell auch besprochen also ich stelle
mir erstmal den Grünen relativ schwierig
vor übers Fracking zu reden ist auch
schwierig auch Atom ist mit grünen
schwierigen und ich finde wir müssten
jetzt eigentlich mal lernen wir können
uns nicht von anderen abhängig machen
und insbesondere von unsicheren
Kandidaten also wenn wir jetzt Strom aus
Österreich beziehen würde ich sagen
können wir uns darauf verlassen da gibt
es freundschaftlich auf sie zu bewegen
ja toben war ja eine ungeheure
herumeierei also man hätte doch ehrlich
gesagt schon jetzt im Sommer sagen
müssen die Kernkraftwerke bleiben am
Netz auch dem Markt im Signal zu geben
wir geben die Energie stellen wir
zuverlässig zur Verfügung
aber wir kämpfen darum weil ich glaube
die Macht ist faktischen von uns alle
einholen
bei diesen Ökologe und damit auch
Umweltexperte selbstverständlich es gibt
ja auch Nachteile beim Fracking und bei
verschiedenen Energielösungen ja es ist
es ist ein massiver Eingriff in in
Gleichgewichte des Erdmantels die wir
schwer abschätzen können in ihren Folgen
und ich bin immer dagegen komplexe
natürliche Systeme die sich über Jahr
Millionen entwickelt haben über Jahr
Milliarden so massiv zu beeinflussen
dass mögliche Schäden in vielen Menschen
Generationen nicht mehr in Ordnung
gebracht werden können und es gibt
Alternativen das selbe gilt ja auch für
den Atomstrom also wo ja allein die die
lagerproblematik nicht gelöst ist weil
es hat unendlich also sehr lange
Halbwertszeiten und wir greifen da ja in
zukünftige Generationen ein aber mit
jeder Tradition
nein es ist egal wo das passiert also
amerikanische Fracking Energie ist
genauso meiner Meinung nach abzulehnen
aber es gibt so viele Alternativen
inzwischen ich weiß nicht ob sie es
wissen also meine Verlobte und ich wir
recherchieren gerade für einen
Dokumentarfilm über ökologische
Energieproduktion und ökologische
Lebensformen und Dank an sie wir haben
jetzt ein sehr interessantes Konzept
entdeckt das ist das die beefazialen
Solarpanels Panels also dass man auf
beiden seitenkollektoren hat
und das können Sie auf diesen riesigen
Agrarflächen die überall in Deutschland
Österreich und überall haben in ganz
Europa können Sie also streifenweise
diese diese
Paneele senkrecht aufstellen so dass Sie
also kaum Fläche brauchen und auch die
Landwirtschaft in den Ackerbau dort
nicht beeinträchtigen und von bei je
nachdem wie die Sonne steht ob sie jetzt
im Osten steht oder im Westen steht je
nach Tageszeit nimmt eben die eine Seite
oder die andere Seite Energie
ausstatten und Landwirtschaft kann die
Landwirtschaft kann auch ein wichtig
eine wichtige Säule der
Energieproduktion werden ganze
Stallungen wir haben auch große
Stallungen und Lagerhallen die können
bedeckt werden mit mit Solarenergie mit
Solarpaneelen Speicherprobleme
lässt sich auch lösen und es gibt
Landwirte die haben in Deutschland die
haben diese Anlagen und sie bräuchten
nur noch den Schalter umlegen und
könnten aufs Netz gehen
alle von ihnen heute Abend noch hören
aber einmal ganz kurz Herr Stock wenn
Sie das Hören hört sich dass sie an als
könnte die Energiekrise heute abend
gelöst werden hier am Tisch von 8:15 Uhr
wäre schön wir blicken Sie denn darauf
gehen aber nein ich krieg da also ich
finde diese Vorschläge faszinierend und
je mehr sie davon erzählen desto mehr
bringen sie das auch zum Leuchten das
finde ich klasse ich glaube nur wir sind
noch ganz weit davon weg wir haben im
Moment glaube ich 17% unseres
Primärenergiebedarfs werden durch
erneuerbare Energien gedeckt das ist
Meilen weit davon weg so also es braucht
und weil das er noch nicht umgesetzt und
was was ja aber auch das ist ein
Baustein und was mich immer stört ist
wenn wir uns auf gewisse Technologien
festlegen dass das Problem wenn wir
Atomkraft ausschalten mit guten
Argumenten dann verhindern wir die
Forschung an Atomkraft die vielleicht
irgendwann dazu führen wird dass wir
diese dieses Lagerproblem in den Griff
kriegen dass wir vielleicht mit einer
einer ganz anderen Technik da
Vorankommen wenn wir uns auf Kohle
festlegen dann verhindern wir das andere
Technologien vorankommen und diese diese
Festlegung aus ideologischen Gründen die
geht mir sowas von gegen den Strich
außerdem ein Punkt dazu noch man muss
auch mal verstehen so toll das ist wenn
wir die ganze Welt mit Solarpaneelen die
so super toll sind Pflastern würden
wirklich auch diesen Quadratmeter das
ist alles voll
das Studio auch es würde uns nichts
nutzen es geht weil Strom kann nicht wir
können Strom aus den Solarpaneelen nur
bekommen solange die Sonne scheinen das
tut sie Gott sei Dank relativ oft in
letzter Zeit sogar häufiger aber wir
können sie nicht so speichern wir haben
36 Pumpspeicherkraftwerke in Deutschland
ist einfach geographisch da ein Ende wir
können ja nicht mehr mitmachen wir
bräuchten erstmal Speicher um diese
Mengen tatsächlich ein speichern zu
können die wir dann am Mittag zum
Beispiel produzieren die Pumpspeicher
sie wissen das wahrscheinlich die haben
bei uns eine Energie von 40 Minuten
Strom Menge mehr nicht wenn Sie alle
funktionieren würden das heißt es ist ja
richtig die Energiewende unterstütze ich
in jeder Regel wenn ich ganz toll ja und
man hätte viel mehr machen können vor
auf vollkommener Chor aber es ist
einfach falsch anzunehmen man könnte nur
mit diesen regenerativen Energien da
muss ich eben wissen also erstens ich
ich schade das jetzt kein Experte für
für erneuerbare Energien hier sitzt ich
bin kein Experte für erneuerbare
Energien als bio-wissenschaftler bin ich
auf die Organismen spezialisiert Mensch
Pflanze Tier und nicht auf die Technik
aber ich weiß dass es zum Beispiel
Konzepte gibt wo ganze Häuser aus sich
heraus energieautark gebaut werden
können da gibt es ein Beispiel ein ein
Konzept das nennt sich die Earth Chips
Earth
geschlossener Wasserkreislauf einerseits
wird gemacht und andererseits wird eben
aufgrund von Solarenergie Windenergie
und wenn möglich auch noch Wasser
entgeht wird auf mehreren Säulen das
Haus vollkommen Energie am Tag zu machen
und das dürfen sie in Deutschland nicht
die Frage wollen sie das den Menschen
vorschreiben wollen Sie also mir sagen
ich baue gerade ein Haus wollen Sie denn
zu mir sagen so Fasching sie müssen das
machen
den letzten Jahren ökologische
Vorschriften was zum Beispiel die
Dämmstoffe betrifft gemacht das wurde
vorgeschrieben aus ökologischen Gründen
wir haben einen Planeten wir haben eine
Planeten und das ist der Planet der auch
den also das konkret nicht es ist ja
nicht einmal erlaubt momentan aber da
fängt sie schon mal an sie dürfen
heutzutage nicht einmal so ohne weiter
Tierhaus energieautark bauen
sie müssen diesen Anschluss ans Netz
haben und da könnte man ja zumindest
einmal diese Tore öffnen das ist leicht
das denen die sie müssen jetzt müssen
Sie nicht machen aber denen die das
machen möchten und es gibt viele
Menschen die aus ökologischen Gründen
was nachhaltigen Gründen für zukünftige
Generationen das auch Freiheit machen
würden das macht denen erleichtern
also wenn sie da Freiwilligkeit setzen
das wird ja dann nicht klappen für die
komplette Energieversorgung also
natürlich werden genauso wie gesagt auch
ökologische oder halt effiziente
Dämmmaterialien vorgeschrieben sind also
man sie können Haus nicht mehr heute so
bauen dass die Energie sozusagen wie in
einer Holzhütte verschwindet sondern sie
müssen da auch gewisse Standards
einhalten und das hat sich in den
letzten Jahren auch immer mehr erhöht
früher waren das die Pioniere des
ökologischen Bauens die Spinner aber
auch für unser Projekt jetzt einiges
interviewt die haben Gegenwind bekommen
heute sind deren damalige Standards
teilweise Vorschrift beim Bauen ja es
gibt Bauvorschriften und es könnte auch
noch mehr Vorschriften geben die müssen
natürlich umsetzbar sein aber es könnte
sich in die Richtung entwickeln dass wir
viel dezentraler das wird auch passieren
dezentraler den Strom produzieren und
Überschüsse dann in ein Netz in ein
gemeinschaftliches Netz abgegeben
hier vorgestellt wird
dementsprechend finde ich das